well could playing video games help some
people who have ADHD there's a clinical
trial underway right here in Las Vegas
to try to determine that eight news now
anchor Kirsten Joyce shows us a look at
whether you or your child might be the
right candidate for the free research
trial
several studies show less than 20
percent of adults with ADHD are aware
that they have it and only about a
fourth of those who do know are getting
treatment for it never sought treatment
and once that happened I was like well I
should have done this years before
Christian hazelbaker of Las Vegas was
diagnosed with ADHD at age 24. after
that diagnosis she signed up for a free
clinical trial at the center for
Psychiatry and Behavioral Medicine in
Las Vegas the first trial I was on
lasted I want to say three months four
months it was a long time she's now
enrolled in a second one under the care
of Dr Ann Childress Childress is an
international specialist who treats ADHD
the majority of her practice is
research-based she's conducted hundreds
of studies and worked with every drug
used to treat ADHD on the market right
now we have a couple of studies for
adults that are going on one is a
non-medication study it's a video
game-like application that we're looking
to see if it will improve attention and
the other study for adults is with a
medication called l-thrionic magnesium
salt it's a non-stimulant so it doesn't
have the same kind of side effects the
stimulants do Dr Childress is looking
for applicants kids adolescents adults
who think they may have ADHD even if
they haven't been officially diagnosed
yet people who don't have a lot of
health problems as she doesn't want
other medications to interfere and you
can't be using marijuana our studies pay
for people to come in they pay for time
and effort our first visit they get
about a thousand dollars worth of free
medical care because we do blood work
and we do physicals and we take a good
medical history hazelbaker is happy to
take part she found a medication that
works for her and hopes her time in the
ongoing study may help others you might
find that this medication works better
for you than the last medication
some of these visits with the clinic
scheduled on Saturdays all the lab work
is done at one location so everything
takes place Under One Roof contact the
center of Psychiatry and Behavioral
Medicine if you are interested you can
find more information on how to sign up
for the study on our website
8newsnow.com now for